reported that four years ago today
in a preseason game
in wisconsin the kaepernick first took a
knee
no this has never happened before but
i'm sure that dr harriet was dr john
carlos
arthur ashe jackie robinson and others
have been praying for this day
shout out to kenny they walked off i
wanted to have a voice in here because i
feel like we only have the same couple
voices talking during these times
so it's very important for me to come
over here i keep hearing the question
like what's next what's next well you
got to plan what's next
you have to figure out what's next um
very proud of the players i don't know
the next steps
don't really care what the next steps
are because the first steps are to
garner attention
and they have everybody's attention
around the world right now
then leadership and others will get
together and decide the next steps
so we know it won't end tomorrow we know
that there's been a million marches and
nothing will change tomorrow
we no vote we keep hearing vote
everybody vote
but i'm here to speak for those that are
always marginalized
those that live in these neighborhoods
where we preach and tell them to vote
and walk away
charles barkley came to my high school
just seeing him in the locker room
seeing his hands and
his body that inspired me you can't see
something
you can't be something until you see it
and when i tell you the little kids that
have called me
upset i have a godsend that has autism
and i just had to explain to him
why we aren't playing
i have young nephews i've had to talk to
about death before they've even seen it
in a movie
if not now when if not doing a pandemic
and countless lives being lost if not
now when that's that's all i just want
to hear from
rest of the night while everybody's
pontificating and thinking and
soapboxing and
all of that we know nothing is going to
change we get it martin luther king got
shot and risked his life mega evers if
we've seen this and all of our heroes
constantly taken down we understand it's
not gonna end
but that does not mean young men that
you don't do anything
don't listen to these people telling you
don't do anything because it's not going
to end right away
you are starting something for the next
generation and the next generation to
take over do you have to be smart yes
do you have to make sure that you have a
plan yes do you have to be articulate
about that plan yes
all of those things but that's what
you're going to do they're professionals
they know how to
be the best of themselves and so i
applaud it
i applaud it because it is the young
people it is the young people leading
the way
and i applaud them